the big short is directed by Adam McKay
and stars Christian Bale Steve Carell
Brad Pitt and Ryan Gosling is the true
story of some analysts working in the
Wall Street area who discover the
eventual collapse of the housing market
in the mid 2000s and it's the inspired
by true story of how they react to that
situation and how they go after big
banks who are completely greedy to try
to make them pay for their mistakes for
once I was looking forward to this film
for just a few reasons for one the cast
is amazing and also I was very curious
to see how Adam McKay handled something
that wasn't anchorman I wanted to see
him do something that was more dramatic
and the best thing I can say about this
movie is that it actually did make me
care about something that I have
virtually no interest in and that is
banking it's not that I don't have
interest in how that affected other
people it's just that I wasn't sure I
was going to enjoy a two-hour movie it's
a lot of numbers and terms that I don't
understand but the movie actually makes
a huge attempt maybe too much of an
attempt to dumb it down for the audience
so that we can find more enjoyment in it
going as far as having celebrity cameos
to explain certain details that we may
not understand sometimes that worked for
me sometimes it was just funny and other
times I was like ok I get it you don't
have to show this person in my face what
I loved most about this movie was the
combination of performance and writing
Christian Bale is freaking fabulous in
this movie as is Steve Carell who proves
in this movie that Foxcatcher wasn't a
one-off for him he is a really great
actor he gave a very angry performance
it's a performance where it's sort of
like he already was an angry person but
as he learns of the corruption and the
greed going on in the big banks and he
realizes what's really happening he gets
more angry but he gets angry for the
right reasons and it really came through
in his performance Christian Bale plays
someone who just knows the numbers he
doesn't know much about people he
doesn't know much about social
interactions he likes to walk around
barefoot in his office and play drums on
his knees while listening to heavy metal
but he predicts this financial crash
just by looking at numbers and he bets
on all the right things to get rich in
the long run and these two central
performances were the strongest in the
whole movie for me and the writing was
really good because the movie traverses
a very
complicated and detail-oriented subject
that most people will be bored by unless
it's presented in a very entertaining
and logical way and it was Brad Pitt
doesn't have much screen time but he is
good in the scenes he is in I'm a big
fan of Ryan Gosling I've liked him very
much as an actor I admire him as a
creator but his performance in this
movie was basically the same character
he played in Crazy Stupid Love so if he
found that character entertaining which
I did you will probably find him
entertaining as well in this movie I
just wish there was a little bit more
behind his character but his character
is really just there to sort of be our
narration and explain things to us also
a lot of characters in this movie break
the fourth wall over and over again
people turn around look at the camera
and tell us things that they're thinking
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
and that leads me to my biggest flaw
with this movie and for some people it
might not be for me the direction and
the style of this movie got on my nerves
sometimes it's very documentarian lots
of crash zooms very purposefully crappy
camerawork and what I mean by that is
they're trying to make it look
unprofessional sometimes that works
because you really do feel like you're
watching real events even though you
know these actors faces and other times
it just felt like a gimmick and I wasn't
always sold on that directing technique
in the long run I thought the big short
was a very good movie very well acted
very well written the direction and the
techniques didn't always pay off for me
but it took a subject that I had
virtually no interested in and made me
care so for that reason I'm going to
give the big short a B+ that is my last
movie review of 2015 if I miss some
movies out this weekend it's Christmas
give me a break I'm trying to catch up
so many movies come out on Christmas
guys I'm looking forward to bringing you
my best and worst of the Year lists very
soon you guys are the best thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes